welcome to this video fernanda motta my
opponent come on let's see oh man
novelty on move 5 and it violates a
couple of opening principles right away
yeah that's a very good line for white
stone gone from yeah he's just it's just
not carrying very much it seems just
going into this unplayable position okay
now g5 maybe even directly yeah it's
very good in any case so rook g1 are not
doing any castling here anymore should
be should be meeting attack on the G
farm
yeah bishop age six is the the direct
idea Joe can still play that why not
don't see why not
this is a very substantial threat if he
takes on f5 Queen f5 Quincy three Kingi
too I mean our king of a king it to air
must play but it's also no problem i
believe
check check yeah i can i can go there
why can I not go to f3 I understand the
look and the queen but I have Queen F of
G seven that's really a quite quite a
big threat queen of two maybe the
defense would be very sick
this may be possible check
okay and here is no wynia really not I
have a hard time to believe that really
do who came right yeah there is a mate
I'm just taking ages to see it Jaclyn 96
Chapman 8 yeah this this is an
absolutely unplayable line this is the
solid stuff after g4 like it's basically
blowing blowing away okay man this 97 I
really wonder why would you need to play
it in four seconds okay after that black
is just losing just loses the porn and
the position on top so I'm very tough to
to continue him not sure okay this isn't
the best yeah okay it isn't the best I
should play Bishop d3 mems the computer
suggestion just keep the pieces on the
water it's not not bad of course just
keep it on the board I mean white has a
pawn in addition to the position okay
well I played hoops i played this and it
seems to have a drawback on ig8 seems to
hold interesting and this also seems to
hold a black is winning here i should
play king everyone Chad problem is
really night h5 as possible him very
very strange move but it's what it's
winning its winning kelvis g7 and its
end up in so only that is really losing
yeah very bad game yeah I felt very much
provoked by this lost opening played
played it a little bit too two
lackluster after all those chances but
ok who
gasps the opponents are playing a very
badly most of the time as well and are
so loose managed to do to blunder it
away okay thanks for watching